Okay. Ready? Hey, I'm Jad
Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radiolab and this whole hour
we have been talking about, go ahead.
Guts, guts.
In the last section we
talked about bacteria and the
armies of them that are in
your gut.
You know the problem is that they're a
little hard to picture kind of abstract.
Oh,
why don't we finish with a story that
makes the whole issue real and much more
concrete.
This is the tail of a
troubled relationship between
a man and his on again,
off again, gut. Yeah. Hello. Hello.
Hello man. His name's John Reiner.
He's a writer, lives here in New York.
So one day you are eating your way
through your life as you usually do.
And then things take an odd turn.
Yeah. How did it, how did it begin?
It began with, the surprise
is at home and I was about to go
make myself a tuna fish sandwich.
John Thought, you know what,
let me go to the bathroom first
to get that out of the way.
So he sits down on the
pot to do his business.
And I felt a funny twinge in my gut.
Now John has had gut pain before.
I suffer from something
called Crohn's disease,
which is a gastrointestinal condition.
But I had gone through a period
of about a year, his remission,
excellent health. And so when this
pain came on, John figured no big deal.
It seemed to come out of nowhere and I
thought it'll go away out of nowhere,
like usual, but it didn't.
Within about a minute,
what was a small twinge all of a sudden
felt like a knife into my gut before
long, I'm on my living room floor,
flat on my back and I can't
move. John calls an ambulance,
they rushed him to the hospital
and when they get there,
the doctors take one look and tell him
your intestines were clock and now they
burst
and it's now spreading bacteria
throughout your system.
Basically you're on the verge of
having Sepsis, meaning you could die.
So you need emergency surgery. But they
also told them that I should recover.
And when he came out of the oir look
like he would, but the doctor said,
let's play it safe. Stay here for a week.
We'll feed you through an IV
and give your gut a break.
So I'm on an IEP for a couple of days
and I've been on nothing by mouth in the
hospital numerous times before,
but always for four to five days.
And after four or five days, John says,
what normally happens is that
you'll start to feel hungry again.
That's a great sign.
That means that your gut is
healing and it's ready for food.
But this time that didn't happen. In
fact, he says he got sicker, nausea,
vomiting, chills, fever, spike.
So the doctors take more pictures of
John's insights and they noticed something
weird in the area where I
had the tear in my intestine.
There is no a Fistula, which is a hole.
And normally this is something
you could so right back up,
the doctors tell them in your case, no,
the tissue of around the area of the
tear so compromised that you can't
withstand another surgery right now.
Plus you've got high level of infection.
Again,
you're no candidate for surgery or only
solution they tell them is to let gut
heal on its own. But in order to do
that, we've got to shut it down. Yes,
basically numb it with anesthesia.
So my gut was in an induced coma.
Nothing would pass through
it. There'd be no activity,
which meant the doctors told
them obviously no eating.
Instead we're going to put you on a food
pump and the food pump is a mechanical
pump about the size and the weight of
two bricks carry carrying in the backpack
and the pump in the backpack is
attached to this big bag. Big Bladder.
The big 3000 milliliter bag of a TPN
is the medical name for the nutrients
visits and for total parent Terrell
nutrition and and stream runs out of the
pump through the tube into my arm.
You are going to be given essentially
a a an outdoor stomach. That's right.
And this is where our story really
begins. So John goes home with his new XO,
stomach canny,
but every day around mealtime he
says he would turn on the food. Yeah.
And this is actually what it sounds like.
[inaudible]
so, uh, I'd start my feeding at
four o'clock. Pump would start,
I'd sit on the love seat for awhile and
my kids would come home from school,
my wife would come home from teaching and
then the real food would come into the
apartment. Sometimes
neighbors brought food over.
Sometimes John's wife
would cook regardless.
I was always sitting on the love seat
in our living room with the food pump
worrying like a dishwasher
while just a few feet away.
His family would sit at the table, uh,
eating fabulous food night after night.
This happens and it's
making me absolutely crazy.
And he says, after about a week of this,
and then two weeks and then three weeks
of just sitting there night after night
watching his family
eat dinner without him,
he says he would start to drift off
and get lost to these really vivid
daydreams of meals that he'd eaten in the
past. One of the first memories I have
is going to Katz's for the first time.
Ladies and gentlemen, please. Getz is
a famous Jewish Jelly in Manhattan. Oh,
how are you doing? Good. All right.
We're going along and
standing there at the counter.
We must be right where the counter man
cuts the Pastrami and puts it on a plate
and it cuts it out of the hot cooker and
it's on a fork and he hands it to you
and you take a taste. And he
says, in that particular instance,
when he took a bite, that first bite
of the astronomy sandwich, it was like,
he said, it was the first time in his
life where he suddenly, he was like,
Oh my God, I'm Jewish. I am
Jewish. She's there. My people.
That was the first time you
felt that it was. It was.
And after about a month of no food at
all, and these vivid daydreams about food,
something happened.
John got Hungry, like actually hungry,
which really doesn't make
much sense because hunger
signals normally travel from
the gut up to the brain, and
his gut was numb. But he says,
he really started to feel hungry.
It was, you know, I think of it,
it was an existential hunger
and he got really bad.
For example, uh,
my wife's a terrific cook
and one night she made a,
a little treat for the kids, uh,
mini burgers and French fries and our
small apartment smelled like the kitchen
of a white castle. So, um,
my wife brought out this big plate of
sliders in a pyramid and the kids were
knocking down the pyramid and throwing
the back and I couldn't take it anymore.
So I snuck out of the living
room while they were preoccupied,
I went into our kitchen and there were
some fries on the stove top and I put my
hand on the fries and I brought them up
to my mouth and I was expecting salt and
oil, fatty goodness, fatty goodness and
the texture of crunchiness and all that.
And I'm tasting it now and I put it
on my tongue and I've got nothing,
nothing really, and I'm
rolling it around and options,
you can't even feel it on my
tongue. Feels even the salt.
It's like when you go to the dentist
and you've got novacane and really,
and my tongue is numb at a roll. So I
start at your tone, just out of practice.
I couldn't figure out what's going on.
And then I brought up a knife and
John claims that when he looked at the
reflection of his tongue
in this metal knife,
I see that my tongue is as flat and
smooth as this for Micah tabletop.
I've got my hand on.
And you're still saying you don't have
the little a personally no bristles.
Right.
And I realize I haven't used it in so
long that my taste buds have evaporated.
You know, they're gone. And at the
moment that that happens, my oldest son,
teddy, who was nine at the
time, comes in and he says, Dad,
you're not supposed to eat. I said to
him, I wasn't eating, I wasn't eating.
It's like you switch places almost.
And he looked at me with
the most scornful disgusted,
just ashamed expression. And
I was completely humiliated.
I normally failed as neater. Shame flood.
Right? I failed as a father as well.
Uh Huh
[inaudible].
As the weeks dragged on and
John didn't get any better,
he actually started to take
that thought seriously.
Like maybe he really was
failing at being a dad.
I'm a stay at home dad
and uh, as a result,
I'm the shopper and the cooker and the
food planner and the provider for us.
And I was out of commission three
years out of work with no gut.
Meanwhile, I can't stop thinking
about food. I'm remembering and
food that I ate 20 years ago.
Like I had it out that afternoon.
And I'm online looking up menus from
restaurants that I've gone to and looking
up recipes, you know, for,
for dishes that I've made.
Obsession grew and grew until one
night he says his neighbor Marsha,
I decided to cook for us one night when
I wasn't eating and she brought down a
chocolate Bundt cake for that.
My wife and kids to eat walks it right
past John on the way to the kitchen.
And I could smell this thing, I could
smell the rum, I could smell the eggs,
I can smell the flower, I could
smell everything. So again,
he sneaks into the kitchen and I lower
my nose down to this bunk cake and I'm
smelling it and I'm sniffing it.
And I'm inhaling this thing
like an anteater and that's
not enough in my state,
so I plunge my hands
into the chocolate cake.
You what? I lunge my hand
You'd order to get one with the Gu or
what order to get some sensation of
connection with food.
Did you think what's happening
to me or did you think, oh,
the moment my fingers were in this cake,
I felt I'm in heaven. I've
reconnected with the living.
I have food if not in me,
at least on me and at
the moment where allowed,
I'm experiencing most pleasure.
My wife comes into the kitchen
when I went in to get the kids
some more food. I found him.
This of course is John's wife Susan with
his hands in the cake just trying to
touch the crumbs and he looked so guilty
and I was also like, why are you doing?
What are you doing? Like somebody's
going through an underwear drawer.
It was very, you know, wrong.
And I have no explanation.
I mean I can say I need to do this.
You have no idea how wonderful this is.
Please give me some time
alone with my bun cake.
It was this bizarrely
funny, but deeply sad,
perverse moments. Yeah.
I suppose it was the first
crack in my, in my bubbled, uh,
attempt to pretend things were normal.
[inaudible]
you know, I realized how
bad things had gotten
[inaudible]
and after that she says things
only got worse. It just became,
there was never anything to be
happy about. He wasn't able to eat,
he wasn't sure what the prognosis was.
He wasn't sure if he was going to need
a second surgery. It was just all bad.
She says John became really depressed
and he became very difficult to even,
not even to cheer up,
but just to say, well,
let's just not talk about
it for now. You know,
he was constantly expressing
his unhappiness was that,
was that the thing? It was just the,
it was dark all the time. Very dark.
Hmm.
It just became very hard to face.
So she left.
Well, I had spring break and
my kids had spring break.
So Susan took the kids to her parents'
place in Indiana for a week. I needed,
I needed to take a break for good.
Maybe the kind of break that means I'm
not really sure what our future looks
like.
I don't know how we're going to do this
and they can't really figure that out
while I'm with you. So I was alone,
not entirely while I was on the
food pump and not doing well.
But after a few days of moping
around the house, John gets an idea.
What I need to get myself out of this
is I need to return to a place of
sanctuary for me.
There was a restaurant not far from
your studio here called Chanterelle.
Uh,
it's a French restaurant and it was one
of these very expensive capital letter
restaurants that my wife and
I had always planned to go to.
If we had a special occasion for years.
I walked past this restaurant and I would
look in the window before getting onto
the subway and I would see
the plates of, you know,
scallops coming out and the
wine steward pouring, you know,
red wine and the handwritten menus
on the tables and things like that.
So I thought if I can get to chanterelle
and if I can look through the window,
then I can heal myself.
[inaudible]
I'll have a reason to hope.
So I got on the subway and it was past
four o'clock and I'm supposed to be home
starting up the pump and feeding and I
got off the subway and I walked over to
Chanterelle on,
I was kind of a little dizzy and
delirious and I get to the window
[inaudible]
and the dining room is empty.
there's dust on the floor, the
wall panels have been stripped,
the tables are bare,
it's empty, it's a cave.
Sometime in the intervening months or
the proceeding months rather chanterelle
has closed. And I didn't know that.
Ah, you're killing me with this story.
And I think to myself, you've reached
the end of the line. This is it.
There's nowhere else to go.
[inaudible]
and um,
I walk towards the river and I know that
people throw themselves in when they do
this. And it never made
sense to me before, you know,
I wasn't ever ready to end
things. Well, you really, uh,
cause I was having
suicidal thoughts. I mean,
I always having really
depressed thoughts and I, I,
and I don't know that I
would have thrown myself in,
but it was the first time I was standing
at the edge thinking about it and
thinking about this is
how these things happen.
So I got to the river and I blacked out.
[inaudible]
collapsed on the sidewalk and
I, I woke up and it was dark.
No,
I had scraped my Chin and my elbows
were bruised and I'd taken a hard fall.
And, um, I got up and I
started to walk around. Uh,
I was on this buckled old sidewalk and
I looked around and there are these
federal era houses and there was a grill,
a gas grill in one of the
backyards that was going,
somebody was cooking dinner
and I could smell it.
I could smell the smoke coming off
the grill and I could smell it.
It was pork chops.
And I was so delirious and so happy to
be smelling food that I took it upon
myself to finish cooking
this guy's meal. So wait,
what? So I, um, it's so
eerie. I lifted up the lid,
I lifted up the lid and it
looked like to me, you know,
one side of the pork shops were cooked
and they were ready to be flipped.
So I flipped them. And, um, I was
so far gone that I thought, okay,
well four more minutes and these babies
are going to be ready to go. And,
and I didn't have a watch.
So I started counting off,
counting down for minutes in my head
because I was going to get this stuff
perfect.
And all of a sudden the back door of this
townhouse opens up and a guy walks out
with an apron on and a cocktail in one
hand and a season Shaker in the other.
And he looks at me and I
look very borderline. I mean,
I'm rail fin. I've got, you know,
I'm caught up from having fallen on
the sidewalk. I've got, you know,
crazy expression in my eyes. I
haven't shaved in, you know, a week.
I looked really very unsavory.
So he sees me and I have
no way of explaining myself
other than to say they're
just about done.
And I hand him the tools and I turn
around and I walk away before he has the
chance to call the police
or anything like that.
How many years ago was this? Uh,
this was now, uh, three years ago.
And what do you take away
from that? Was that, uh,
was that some kind of turning point
where you walk away from the grill and
you're ready to fight the
good fight or what? Um,
that only happens in the
movies and in fairytales.
But actually happened
was I got sick again. Uh,
I had another infection, more bacteria,
and I had to go back to the hospital.
And when I went back to the
hospital this time they said, okay,
we can't even do the food pump anymore
because you keep getting these infections
and if the bacteria spreads to your
bloodstream through the food pump,
but then you'll be gone and we can't
operate on you because you won't survive
the surgery. So all we
have left is to try eating.
The only thing that's left is to go
back to food cause you can't ingest it
intravenously.
We're afraid of infection and we
can't repair your gut surgically.
So the only way you can keep yourself
alive is to try to use your gun again.
Huh? So they start you on a,
on around have a, I don't know,
baby food gerbers I did start on the
traditional applesauce and Jello and
putting soft and easily digested
foods. And John says they worked,
his body was able to take the food
but I couldn't taste anything.
And it continued that way
for another couple of months.
And a deferred ever tastes like food
again. Well I was at the radiologist,
the scene, the scene I was
expecting. Yeah. Well you know,
I have a little ritual with
this particular radiologist.
He's on the east side and
whenever I get tests there,
when I'm done with the tests,
I'm able to eat again. And again,
this is when you do test prep, you're
going about 24 hours without eating.
So you know,
the thought of food becomes a celebration
that you're going to have. Right?
So there's a diner on third
avenue and 84th street,
a fifth street that I always go to
and I get the same meal every time.
I sit at the counter and I get fried
egg and Bacon Sandwich on whole wheat
toast.
So I went there and I got the last seat
at the counter and I ordered my usual
and I chew into it and I realized that
I've got sort of embryonic flavors going
on.
I've got the sort of the start of the
sensation of tasting and the start of
flavors in my mouth and I could feel
that great combination of the fried egg
congealing with the crunchy bacon and
the crunchy toast. And I do the same,
you know, mirror.
I've got a knife about a knife and I do
the same mirror knife examination at the
counter and I can see that where before
it was shiny and smooth as a porpoise.
I've got little bristles,
I've got little bumps on my tongue and
I can taste this fantastic $3 sandwich.
Do you kiss the lady
sitting next to you? Well,
I turned to the guy sitting
next to me and I tell him,
this is the best damn
thing I've ever eaten.
And in classic New York diner fashion.
Okay. Ready? Hey, I'm Jad
Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and this whole hour we
have been talking about good guts guts.
In the last section we
talked about bacteria and the
armies of them that are in
your gut. Yeah.
The problem is that they're a little
hard to picture kind of abstract. Oh,
why don't we finish with a story that
makes the whole issue real and much more
concrete.
This is the tail of a
troubled relationship between
a man and his on again,
off again, gut. Yeah. Hello. Hello.
Hello man. His name is John Reiner.
He's a writer, lives here in New York.
So one day you are eating your way
through your life as you usually do,
and then things take an odd turn.
Yeah. How did it, how did it begin?
It began with the surprise.
I'm his at home and I was about
to go make myself a tuna. Yeah.